we're looking ahead in the political
season now looking ahead to the race for
henderson mayor michelle romero one of
the
uh candidates for mayor on the council
right now thank you for joining us to
talk a little bit about
uh this campaign on the horizon how are
you doing thank you for having me i'm
doing well
so you've already declared that you're
running for mayor of henderson
you've been involved in city politics
and in city
government for some time just as mayor
what are some of the main things that
you would like to see
changed if you were able to be mayor
not necessarily change but things i want
to improve upon and add upon we've
already built a really great base in
henderson it's a great place to be it's
a great place to do business
the four things that i want to focus on
as mayor are
public safety first education second
transparency in government and economic
development and diversifying our economy
and the efforts that we've already
started to do
let's take one of those take all of
those one at a time here talking about
public safety
there's been some movement with regards
to the henderson police department for
the last couple of years
the old police chief left there's
litigation i think still ongoing with
that
instead of focusing on that let's just
talk more about trying to bridge the gap
at city hall between the department the
union and the community how would you
achieve that
you know i'm already working on that
that i work with our police department
on a daily basis almost i i meet with
them regularly
i reach out to our captain that's in
charge of my ward
i get information on what's happening
with not only the community but with the
police officers themselves
you know they they experience things
that we never want to see
they're they're there when we're on our
worst day and so i have developed that
rapport with them and i have a great
respect for the work that they do
and henderson is known as one of the
safest cities in america and it's for a
reason
it's because safety is priority for us
and
we continue to work to make sure they
have the tools necessary to keep
themselves safe
to keep them on the cutting edge of
technology
and to make sure that they recognize
that they're valued their life is
important to us and that that their
safety is first as well
was the transition at the head of the
police department satisfactory in your
mind as someone who on the council at
the time
do you think the city has handled that
appropriately so i wasn't on the council
at the time of the transition but i i
believe
based on the information that i have
that it was a good decision and
you know we i meet with the new chief on
a regular basis he does a really good
job
of making sure that i'm aware of what's
happening with his
force the things that are important to
them and the things that maybe are on
the horizon that we need to
really focus on to make sure that we
continue to be safe as we continue to
grow
another issue you brought up is
education one of your uh
stances is trying to separate henderson
with its own school district i believe
there's been a long standing effort to
try and separate ccsd
how would you achieve this goal of
getting henderson its own school
district
well i think we're starting to lay the
groundwork now henderson is the only
city
in the valley that has its own community
education advisory board
and through that board we use 30 percent
of our marijuana funds and 18 percent of
our redevelopment funds to directly fund
henderson public schools and so we've
set the groundwork already for
identifying a funding source and for
ensuring that that our our residents
know that education is top priority
the next thing i've asked our staff to
do and that is already underway is to
looking into
whether or not we can form our own
charter school system
so that we get that already in place and
there's an alternative it'll take a
while to to break up the school district
as you just as you just mentioned
and so we've already done that by
establishing a pre-k program to make
pre-k
available to all children in henderson
we have our own
it's operating at full capacity and it's
it's doing wonderfully well
so i'd like to take that to the next
level and open a charter school
and have that same result as we continue
to work on
and allowing municipalities to separate
or opt out of the school district system
what's wrong with ccsd why separate you
know i think despite
i think every single person at the
school district wants what's best for
our kids i think they all
try their best to make sure that happens
it's just too big there's
it doesn't matter who would be at the
helm it's too big to operate
it doesn't get the the results that we
need to see we just had
a report from the school district at a
recent council meeting
and it continued to reinforce that fact
so we need to do things differently we
need to try alternatives
to make sure that our kids aren't last
or look close to last in the nation in
education
you know i seem to remember even when i
went to school here there were talks of
trying to split up ccsd it's not a new
discussion and not a new issue and
there's always resistance from a variety
of different parties unions legislatures
lawmakers etc
how do you how do you navigate that you
talked about some of the things that are
already in the works but in terms of
actually splitting off
you would have to acknowledge that it's
not as easy as just i would like to
split away
you're right it's a long process and it
would involve getting
a large group of people together all
working in the same direction
since the the pandemic and the kids have
been having the kids home at school home
from school
there's been quite a a raising of
awareness of the need
for different something different i
think there are a lot of people now that
are thinking along those same lines
whereas maybe there wasn't that
groundswell before
and getting those partners together to
work toward the same goal it's going to
take
partnerships with the private sector
with the public sector
and with parents and families you uh
now another issue you brought up
transparency
a long-standing concern from some in the
community is the lack of transparency
whether it's public records whether it's
ability to speak at city council
meetings before and during the pandemic
this isn't a new concern that's been
brought up with the city of henderson
what do you plan to do to address this i
think prior to the pandemic we had
already started efforts to
to approach that we had council
conversations where we would just have
kind of an open forum for residents to
come and meet with their council people
to ask whatever questions
we would bring members of our staff
that were in various departments so that
they could answer questions
and it was just kind of an open forum so
residents were aware of what's happening
what's on the horizon and to voice their
concerns
the mayor did same thing with with her
march on series where
same same thing happened with a specific
topic
that needs to continue as we went
through the pandemic henderson was
i think the only one who had multiple
avenues of participation for our public
meetings when they couldn't come in
person we made sure that they could
participate electronically we made sure
that they could
that they could come on through zoom or
or other mechanisms
and we we adjusted our entire system of
public meetings to make sure that there
were multiple opportunities for people
to chime in on whatever
whatever their concern was a lot of what
you just mentioned though isn't
those aren't earth-shattering ideas
every city had some form of
public comment every municipality
virtually during the pandemic
county commissioners have had county
conversations for a long long time they
go out and have coffee around their
jurisdiction or whatever
so those don't sound like new ideas so
you're describing things that are
already
that some people are criticizing or say
isn't enough
is there anything else that you would
like to address so moving forward
one of the things that that i think
people would like to see is they don't
get to speak with their council people
very often
one-on-one they don't either answer the
phone or they don't
show up so that's something that i have
done throughout my
actually throughout my my tenure at the
city and as as a council person
i'm actually very open door if they
email me i respond
if they call me i respond if they you
know show up to my office i have an open
door and i let them in and i
actually they feel like they are heard
and i get
feedback on that on a regular basis
so that's something i would like to
encourage more of something that we
recently started
was is having roundtable discussions
with our development community
to get feedback on how henderson is
doing and what we could do better to
make sure that the
the process is easier i've been doing
the same thing by reaching out to our
business community and making sure that
what they are experiencing is what
they'd like to see happen that
they are getting the greatest support
possible and i think
it's not earth-shattering but it's
simple to have that one-on-one
interaction and actually have
communication both ways and have
people feel like they've been listened
to goes a long way toward making them
feel like that we're being transparent
one of uh when the discussion of the
dollar loan center as it's called now
uh came up in the deci the votes were
taken to eventually green light the
redevelopment of the pavilion
uh you talk about having people allow
them to have their say
those who were involved the rather vocal
opposition to that project
would suggest they didn't have their say
how do you address
their concerns that i acknowledge the
obviously the arena is being built now
but those are lingering concerns that
were brought up pretty significantly at
that time
so when those people came out i actually
went out and met with them in person i
walked to the site with them
i listened to all of their concerns and
and the vast majority of the concerns
were
traffic potential traffic implications
the visibility that
the the building might impede their
visibility
open space and the availability to to
interact in the open space
and parking so all of those ideas i
brought back
and those were all incorporated with the
building design
so parking has been addressed there have
been more than a thousand parking spots
added to the site without disrupting any
of the existing parking
the building will sit actually nine feet
lower than the previous building
so that that that is not an issue we've
already let out the contract for
the traffic looking at the traffic and
how that might
have impacts we're looking at um
traffic sensing software that will make
sure that the traffic moves smooth
moves smoothly and then we've also made
it so before
the the pavilion not only was it losing
a million
plus dollars a year and was not usable
you know half the year it had just
problem after problem after problem
that that wasn't sustainable so this pl
this new design will have an open space
that has a variety of different issues
or uses that that can be
done on the site and it will be open 24
hours it's not behind a fence like the
previous one it's open all the time and
it'll be for the
for the public to enjoy so i would say
to them that all of their
concerns were definitely heard were
communicated to the design team and were
enacted
but the decision was made during the
pandemic when cuts were being made and
yet
you the project is you know half and
half split with the vegas golden knights
organization
so can the city still afford this
project absolutely
so at the same time as we issued bonds
for this project we
refunded or refinanced some of our
existing bonds which saved
millions of dollars and with that
savings the savings we had
cover the cost of the of the new bonds
and so there was really no change in
what
what has been made and from my
experience
working at the city i know the efforts
that our
finance staff goes through prior to even
coming to us for a bond
and the vetting that has been done to
make sure that worst case scenario
those bonds can be paid and that had all
happened and they had made their
their projections and and evaluated what
the situation was
and how we could cover those bonds
everything looked
great and it has all played out exactly
like they had predicted it would and
and we're in a very good position we'll
now have an 80 million dollar building
that the city only had to pay 40 million
dollars for and we'll have a
professional
sports team that does entertainment uh
for their
you know for their living program
in the space so that we have
professionals doing that as well this is
the best of both
both worlds so the the dollar loan
center
is one of many developments happening in
in henderson there's the area around the
raiders
practice facility there's water street
which obviously as we were talking
before you are heavily involved in
uh there are some major developments on
the horizon how do you hope to or how do
you plan to if you're elected as mayor
continue that growth and and draw more
development into the city
henderson is very fortunate in that we
have people coming to us now and so we
can afford to be very choosy
about who we allow into the city and we
are looking for what's the highest and
best use for the
the limited space that we have available
and we have a very good vetting process
we have an
excellent economic development team a
great redevelopment team
you know everybody from community
development to fire to police are
looking at every project to make sure
that it
crosses all the teas and dots all the
eyes and meets all of the goals that we
have set for the city
to make sure that we're creating jobs
good paying jobs
that have minimal impacts on the
surrounding area and add value to our
city
dan stewart is your opponent right now
for mayor someone you're familiar with
what do you think set yourself apart
from mr stewart
i think our experience is what sets us
apart the most i have
both the the experience 25 years in the
public sector
for my work with the city and in in
redevelopment and then after i retired i
opened my own business became a small
business owner
and worked on the other side of the
table so i could see how
city decisions impacted business
operations on the private side
and how those could be mitigated some
some of the things that that were you
know decided that that
maybe have impacts on the business
community that weren't thought of
and so i have that both sides of the
table experience and besides that i was
a i'm a
long time native of henderson and and i
have that experience from
from all the feedback i get from friends
and family and
people have lived here a long time i
have a very unique background and very
unique experience that i think
makes me the best candidate so what's
your number one priority if you're
elected mayor
number one priority is public safety
without public safety we don't have
anything nobody's going to want to live
here nobody's going to want to send
their child to school
or open a business we've got to make
sure that we have public safety officers
in place
at enough levels to keep our city safe
and are the levels are where they should
be now
we're getting there we're getting there
it it slowed down for a period of time
but in the
in the new budget we have we're adding
more officers and we're continuing to
look down the line to see what's needed
in what areas
michelle romero good luck in your
campaign for mayor of henderson we'll
keep an eye on how the race goes
appreciate it thank you for joining us
thank you very much